hey crew it's Wednesday slowed it up the
bikes getting ready to head down to the
ocean roll dogs going to do a swim such
a beautiful day today amazing view
Kailua Kona Wednesday we're leaving Shay
luster he lives up on a hill above ke
ho-bag that high up we're like how far
up are we thousand thousand feet so we
got a nice view of the ocean from up
here we got a really clear beautiful day
we're going to show you a killer view
right now down the end of my street come
out here on a run and we're just so
blessed to be able to call Kailua Kona
Hawaii home and today we're going to go
to rich Bulldogs and go down to a swim
in the ocean and then we're going to
bounce out we're going to go to Waimea
but check this out here you can see
that's the pier down there to the right
that's where the Ironman start is and
that's basically Downtown Kona and on a
very clear view ttle day you can
actually see Maui from here and then
that what do you say I'm going to check
out the weather and see about going up
into Waimea climb the call us today
yo talk some pills but we basically just
packed up our whole house and computers
and everything because we're going to
actually go do work down in white
today check this out there you go we
headed down the hill towards the ocean
see the downtown Kona down there the
cruise ship coming in will be a lot of
tourists walking around down I'll be
here over the mountains it's actually a
thousand foot climb so any any time you
finish a long bike ride you've got a
thousand feet at the end to climb up so
it's a pretty good training all right
thanks for joining us we'll check in
with you a little bit later on
peace out law all right rich and Jason
we're up in Waikoloa getting ready for a
ride and head out up to Waimea do some
climbing got a beautiful day here today
except the weather holds up this guy's
here out on the lava fields Sun is
scorching and we're psyched we can only
get rolling takes forever get all your
stuff bring us out by we've been like
screwing around for what seems like
forever anyway we're heading out and
check in with you later
time and why wait boy I'm mayor right
now
uh TT minutes in your 45 minute interval
we're only five percent grade right now
but Pyrates 156 working pretty hard it's
hot out here we got a nice day and
Jason's back there just checking in
halfway through this con and I'll check
in with you from the top all right here
we are win wine now before I there just
finished that Klein
2,500 feet up about 45 minutes get up
here and
fuel hydration
climb up the house still checking
all right so here I am at the bottom of
the climb up to Waimea all the way to
the top a little bit in a decline I kind
of lost touch with Jason I thought I
would see him on the way down but I
didn't see him and I'm having trouble
getting ahold of him so I don't know
what to do we were going to go down this
road it's a Kauai high and then climb up
into hobby but I think what I'm going to
do is now I'm going to climb back up to
Waimea I find chase on the way out
otherwise I probably climb back down and
go down this road back to the car back
to rock to lower back car so I don't
know where he is I don't know how I
could have missed him on the road coming
back down so it's bizarre he's not
answering his phone so it's a bit of a
mystery and try to solve a mystery now
so
hey Korea just finished finished I'll go
to four-hour ride we had to 45-minute
climbs so we we drove down here to
Waikoloa and we rode up to Waimea and
then we climbed up qahal us we're just
checking in with you check out the new
never stop pump thanks suit for the
compression calf socks wrote it we wore
them on the rut right today and sandals
for after training
and our zoo bottles roll dog should be
here any minute just got a text from
roll city was heading back in we got
split up up in the koalas because the
guy's a beast he likes the hammer the
hills what happened all right
yeah we got all confused where did you
would it I went all the way to Waimea to
the Starbucks you weren't very far ahead
of me I could see you bro but then once
we took that turn to go like you either
go left hollering or right to Waimea I
like I lost you like I couldn't see you
up there yeah and I was wondering man I
was thinking Jason might think I'm gonna
just go alcohol is like if I was a real
man muscle oh cool
well so I went into town but I was
already at I was like right at 45
minutes right as that right at that
intersection good log basically code so
it's like I just like I didn't I didn't
know how much fur I knew the town was
closed I didn't know how close I was
like I'll just stop
yeah
so when I came back down when I saw me I
was done I was that's like that's why I
yell feels like you don't want to call
her and I went all the way down quiet I
didn't notice you said do you know what
to call I thought you said dude what's
your problem
I said you owe me two Kahala and then by
that time I was like what dude he's
going back up to right man I'm gonna
head back here and I thought we started
at 12:30 I wasn't off my bike at all the
whole trip so if we started at 12:30 I
got here at 4:30 and it was pretty so
beautiful I'm like dude please be up
here and so I knew you were up dinner so
that kept going so I went mile 405 I'm
like he's already at the pool and I was
like you know I saw some dude off to the
side taking pictures I'm like there he
is
I didn't see you so that was kind of
addicting because when you go around a
corner and it's like still climbing and
went all the way to the funny thing
about that climb is that it looks worse
than it is like from the road you see
all those cars driving up door and your
life it looks like you know lqs it looks
like it's gonna kill you but it's
actually dude that client right there's
harder it was good I like that climb
because it never nail get